March 1st, 2025, 7am, a Venezuelan
warship sails within 700 meters of an
American oil platform, producing over
200,000 barrels daily.
Over the radio, you are operating in
Venezuelan waters, but the warship is
deep inside territory Guyana has
controlled since 1899.
To understand what's really happening, I
went through the original 1899
arbitration records.
15 volumes of British diplomatic cables
and interviews with indigenous leaders
whose families have lived in this
territory for generations.
Here's what the documents actually show
about Venezuela's claim
to two-thirds of Guyana.
26 days after that warship confrontation,
US Secretary of State Marco
Rubio lands in Georgetown.
At the joint press conference with
Guyana's president,
Rubio stares into the camera.
It would be a very bad day for the
Venezuelan regime if they were to attack
Guyana or Exxon Mobil.
We have a big navy. It would not end well
for them. Within hours Maduro fires back.
There goes the imbecile Marco Rubio,
threatening Venezuela from Guyana.
No one threatens Venezuela because this
is the homeland of the liberators.
That confrontation made global headlines.
But let me tell you who actually lives in
the territory they're fighting over.
125,000 people, 90% of them indigenous.
Jean Larose is a Lacona woman who won the
Goldman Environmental Prize in 2002 for
coordinating Guyana's first indigenous
land rights lawsuit.
In April 2024 she wrote, "We do not
recognize borders. We recognize the river
that gets us to one place.
We recognize the mountain we must cross
to get to one place."
Lloyd Pereira is the Toshao, that's the
chief of Wacapoa
village on the Pomeroun River.
When Venezuela held a referendum claiming
his home, he told Al Jazeera,
"Even as a small boy, I remember hearing
Venezuela saying, "Esequibo is theirs."
But I also know I live in Esequibo. And
as an indigenous
person, Esequibo is ours."
Derek John, chairman of the National
Toshao Council,
explained the stakes at COP 28.
"If Venezuela should have its way, then
we will lose
everything we have achieved."
"We have fought for and we
have protected for centuries."
Here's the thing. 126 years ago, when
European powers
decided who owned their land,
not a single indigenous
person had a say in that decision.
On October 3rd 1899, an arbitration
tribunal meets in Paris.
Five men, two British jurists, two
American judges representing Venezuela,
and one Russian jurist decide who
controls 159,000 square
kilometers of territory.
The proceedings last 55 days, not one
indigenous person is in that room.
The tribunal issues its
ruling, what's called the award.
Britain gets roughly 90%
of the disputed territory.
Venezuela gets the mouth of the Oricono
River. Now watch what
Venezuela does next.
For 63 years, they don't just accept this
ruling, they actively implement it.
From 1900 to 1904, a joint commission
walked the entire
boundary and planned markers.
On January 10th 1905, both
sides signed an agreement,
confirming the coordinates. In 1931, they
build a monument at Mount Raraima,
where three borders meet. In 1941,
Venezuela's foreign minister calls the
frontier well-defined and a closed issue.
Then suddenly, on February 14th 1962,
Venezuela tells the UN there's a dispute.
What changed?
British Guiana is about
to become independent, and
Venezuela has just read a posthumous
memorandum from one of their own 1899
lawyers claiming fraud.
But that 1962 rejection is nothing
compared to what happens in 2015.
May 20th 2015, ExxonMobil announces the
LISA 1 discovery offshore Guiana.
Initial estimates
suggest 700 million barrels.
Later discoveries
reveal 11 billion barrels.
Seven days later, literally
seven days, on May 27th 2015,
Venezuela publishes a decree claiming
sovereignty 200 miles
into Guiana's waters and
authorizing the Venezuelan
navy to secure this area.
The documentary record shows us exactly
where Venezuela's position changes.
And it changes the weak
ExxonMobil strikes oil.
By 2024, Guiana is producing
over 650 000 barrels daily.
The economy has tripled.
ExxonMobil has committed over 60 billion
to offshore projects.
Five days after the
December 2023 referendum,
Maduro orders Venezuela's state oil
company to immediately
grant operating licenses for the
exploration and exploitation of oil, gas
and mines in Esequibo.
Not study it. Immediately exploit it.
Now, Venezuela teaches every school child
that the 1899 arbitration was a fraud.
The story.
The American judges were coerced by the
Russian president who secretly met with
British arbitrators.
Venezuela was robbed.
This comes from that memorandum written
45 years after the tribunal
and published posthumously in
1949. The author, Malet Pravost, claims
the Russian jurists
offered the Americans a choice.
Accept a unanimous ruling or
face an even worse decision.
But when you look at the actual
documents, the story falls apart.
In 1950, American legal scholar Clifton
Child examined 15 volumes
of British foreign office
papers. Every single document from those
years, the tribunal
proceedings and British newspaper
coverage. His conclusion? Not a single
document indicates a
secret deal. Zero evidence. More
damaging. Justice Brewer himself praised
the British
arbitrators on July 23rd, 1899,
during the proceedings. He said he had
"great admiration for the
impartial and strict sense
of justice shown by the British
arbitrators." That's not
how coerced judges talk.
The questions are obvious. Why wait 45
years? Why publish only after death?
Why never protest publicly?
Now let me tell you about Venezuela's
claim to protect
indigenous peoples in Nisequivon.
About 2,500 indigenous Warao people have
fled from Venezuela
to Guyana as refugees.
There's also violence. In January 2018, a
young indigenous
Guyanese miner was tortured by a
Venezuelan gang. The cut of his ears
beheaded him and posted the
video online. In March 2025,
Venezuela claimed they'd held community
assemblies in
Nisequivon. The National Toshawas
Council called these claims completely
false and confirmed no such community
assemblies took place.
Venezuela has never consulted the
indigenous peoples who
actually live there. Meanwhile,
here's what's happening to those
communities right now. Parabara is a
village of about 200
YY and Makushi people. A 2017 study found
100% of participants had
elevated mercury levels,
averaging more than 10 times the WHO safe
limit. The mercury comes
from gold mining operations
upstream. Mining camps have more than
doubled since 2024. Fish
is the main protein source.
The community knows about the
contamination, but what choice do they
have? This is happening
under Guyana's administration and
Venezuelan control offers
no promise of improvement.
Venezuela's state oil company has one of
the worst environmental
records in Latin America.
On February 17th, 2025, six Guyanese
soldiers were shot in an ambush by
Venezuelan gang members.
On May 25th, 2025, Venezuela held
elections for a
territory it doesn't control,
defying an international court of justice
order. The ICJ ruled 12-4
in Guyanese favor in 2020,
then 14-1 in 2023. The final judgment is
expected in 2026. The 1899
arbitration excluded indigenous
peoples entirely. In 2025, they're still
excluded from
decisions about their own land,
except now there's 11 billion barrels of
oil in the balance.
Lloyd Pereira, the toshao of
Huacapua village, said it simply, "I am
Guyanese. A sequibo is my home. It
belongs to Guyana. I will
die here." History isn't destiny, but oil
apparently can make you rewrite it.